In this video, I'll cover
two important
structures in any language--
the if statement and
logical operators.
I'll also introduce this if/else
and which functions.
I'm going to occasionally rely
on the stock data used the
last video, but to keep things
simple, I'm also going to omit
any rows that have an NA value,
as these represent
missing observations
in the data.
An if statement is used to
execute some section of code
on the condition that a
particular statement is true.
In this setup, the code inside
the braces will run if the
condition is true.
For example, suppose I want to
check whether the first entry
in the stock data
was up or down.
If it was up, I want to create
a variable called status that
takes the value up.
It would also be informative to
label the status as down if
the stock is down.
So I'll add an else statement.
The code in the second set of
braces will execute if the
condition is false.
However, this still
isn't quite right.
What if the stock opens and
closes at the same price?
I can add a condition for the
second set of code using a
second if statement after
the else command.
Then, I'll add another else
command at the end that labels
status with a value of flat if
the stock is flat for the day.
I also want to briefly mention
the if/else function, which
could be used in this context
to create an up, down, flat
vector for all the elements in
the stocks data in just a few
lines of code.
The if/else function takes
three arguments--
a vector of length one or more
that contains true and false
values, a value to take for
each true instance, and a
value to take for each
false instance.
Though this still isn't quite
right, because I need to
return a value of down if the
close is lower than the open.
I can do this by creating the
second condition, and I'd need
one more if/else command.
Here, I've done something
subtle.
I have provided the status
argument for those cases where
the close is not lower
than the open.
I've exploited a special
feature of the if/else
function, which is that when a
vector of length greater than
one is provided in the second
or third arguments, if/else
will be performed,
element-wise, for that argument.
I'll leave it to you to
verify that this code
works and why it works.
You should think about
each possible case.
A stock can be up, down, or
flat, and I strongly recommend
you create some test data and
work your way through each
step of the code.
Next, I want to talk about
logical operators.
I'm going to create a vector
with 10 random integers
between negative 1 and
13, and a second
vector in the same way.
I'd like to know whether all
of the elements in x are
greater than zero.
I might intuitively start by
using the command x>0.
However, as R does in many
other scenarios, it also
performs this check
element-wise.
Here you can see I
have a vector of
true and false values.
I can use the all function
around x>0 to answer the
question as to whether all
of the values of x are
greater than zero.
We can also check other things,
such as, do any
elements of x line up
with those in y?
This, again, returns a vector
of true and false, but this
time, I can use the any function
to check whether any
of the values are equal.
We can also do other checks
that relate x and y.
For example, consider the
separate commands x>0 and y>0.
If I wanted to check in which
elements this was true in both
vectors, I could use a single
ampersand between the commands.
Here, the single ampersand means
to check whether both
the first and the second
condition are true on an
element-wise basis.
There's a similar or command
using a pipe, or a vertical
line character, that creates
an element-wise basis on
whether one statement or the
other statement is true.
R, like other languages, also
has a double ampersand and
double pipe notation, though
I'm going to move on.
If you're interested in this,
you should check out the help
file for x or.
The last topic I wanted to cover
in this video is the
which function, used to identify
which elements or
observations satisfy a
particular condition.
For example, I'd like to know
which observations had a big
intraday fluctuation.
To begin, I'll create an object
called fluctuation that
gives the raw intraday
fluctuation.
I can scale the fluctuation by
dividing the difference by the
opening share price
of the day.
Next, I'll create a condition
for whether the fluctuation
was greater than say, 25%.
This is a Boolean vector of
true and false values that
report whether each row in the
data frame satisfied or did
not satisfy this big fluctuation
condition.
If I wanted a vector reporting
just those rows that satisfy
the condition, I can use
the which function.
These rows represent
observations where the stock
price fluctuated by more
than 25% in a day.
If I wanted, I could examine
each of these rows in the
original data set.
In the next video, I'll
talk about for loops.